so who's my guest this week the british
lawmaker and activist baroness jane
campbell
when you've originally been given a life
expectancy of two years you know how to
make the most of your time
born with spinal muscular atrophy in an
era when the world was an even harsher
environment for those with disabilities
she's fought politicians around the
globe challenging segregated schools
battling for access to transport
independent living and then became a
politician herself she was made a
baroness in the uk parliament
blocking laws for euthanasia
even in the face of some passionate
advocates who are pleading to die if i
should ever sit down the last thing i
want is
for you to give up on me she says
disability isn't her problem it's
societies and she will change society
here's a taste
what is top of your list to achieve for
those living with disabilities around
the world i just want them to feel alive
and i want them to be to enable them
in some way
to feel empowered because once you get
involved if you have a bit of confidence
you can do anything
hello thank you so much for talking to
me and to all of us today
i'm very pleased to be here i've wanted
to start by asking about spinal muscular
atrophy and what it means to you as
someone living with it
to be absolutely honest i don't really
think about it i don't wake up in the
morning and think oh i've got swear to
myself
what's gonna happen with my body today
i just tend to
get on with life i've lived with that
since i was born it's
part of who i am um my parent doesn't
define me but it certainly
is a reason for
why i am sitting with you through here
today talking about some of the things i
do because
my
impairment my condition whatever you
want to call it
it's something that i'm just
used to it's my friend
it can be my enemy it gives me a hard
time sometimes and
it is progressing so
i have to keep up with it and keep
inventing
new ways to do things
and when people if they say to you
what is wrong if they even put it like
that to you do they say that all the
time right so
what do you say i recognize that your
relationship with it's different and
you've only known this
well it depends on what kind of mood i
mean
to be honest if somebody comes up and
they're younger
they're you know knowledgeable and i
think they should know better and they
say so what's wrong with you then i
normally go
well i'm a bit broke at the minutes but
apart from that i'm fine
what's wrong with you and
then they'll go well no no no i don't
mean that like i talked what do you need
and if they want to pursue it but by
this time i hope they get the message
um
they'll ask me no
what's your condition you know why are
you in a wheelchair and i go um well
um that depends why do you want to know
what would you like me to tell you
because
i want people to
think
what is behind that question why do they
want to know i was going to ask about
assumptions people make and perhaps some
of the more frustrating ones that you
just wish weren't part of of how you
were perceived
i think they have assumed that i must be
in pain or that i must be
upset when i'm in a wheelchair
or that my life doesn't have
the same things that
the nurse does they think that for some
reason i don't go to the pub or i don't
go to the sincere performance of swan
lake so they're all open house because
how would i i'm in a wheelchair
um that still happens it's a lot lots
better
but
you know in my youth i couldn't go into
a cinema
because people thought i was a fire risk
you know somehow i wouldn't get out and
i could get out the cinema probably
quicker than you it was your dad i
understand who who never took no for an
answer for you no my dad was
more bloody minded than i am but
he
he was always determined that i would be
treated exactly the same as my sister
which was um
tough on me at times you know i had to
do
all the same things as she did you know
chores around the house okay
i couldn't take them too bad but i could
do the wiping out
i was treated equally at home
i wasn't treated any equally anywhere
else when i was at home so
he would drag me and my sister to
museums and parks and and the circus and
he'd even hit me up on
the merry-go-rounds and the in the
bumper cars at the event there it's
because he wanted me to experience what
it like was actually
just
ordinary
and he pushed me hard
well we are hearing some of the fruits
of that in terms of where you've got to
and what you've been able to do which
we'll also come into more detail but
just something you said about
getting to people's homes and if they
asked you what they could do it made me
think of i read a recent report of
someone preparing to take a refugee from
ukraine and they are repurposing their
home for a family who have a disabled
son he's in a wheelchair living with
disabilities and i wonder
what your reflections are thinking about
that because when we think about war we
don't necessarily think about those who
are living with disabilities yeah i
think the first
moments that we were hearing about
what was happening in ukraine i
immediately thought about the 2.7
million disabled people that were living
in the uk
i was thinking well what would i do if
suddenly i couldn't be in my home and i
was down at the tube station and there
was nowhere to plug my ventilator into i
would be dead
so
this
war is going to
profoundly affect the lives of disabled
people and those who are at the most
vulnerable edge of society and we
already know that
there's a lot of children
living in some of their residential
homes because they do still have a lot
of residential homes um
my kids are shut away
some of them i have heard i've been just
left there to die
because you know
in many ways it's the survival of the
fittest and i'm afraid
that is true
we don't like to think about it we all
think about
compassion when it comes to
to disabled people to older people
but there is a dark side of all that
where there isn't the compassion
compassion it's where actually
vulnerable people
of any sort are
subject to bullying and
left to fend for themselves yeah i
haven't heard anybody talk about that
no you won't we don't even talk about it
in our own country no but with regards
to war in this most recent yeah well
that's what i'm trying to find out at
the moment um through the u.n
you have a un committee on the rights of
disabled persons and they have set up
some charities
um
directly for this purpose to find out
where are they
are they still alive and how can we help
it's a very important
it's a very important area of work to
keep going with even in war but i think
the idea of survival of the fittest is
is something i'll definitely remember
when we're thinking about this because i
hadn't started in those terms even
though i was thinking about just this
family trying to prepare them yes
good on that family i you know i would
want to go give them a hug because
not many people would think like that
and the survival element has been key
especially when as you say you're up
against a deteriorating uh
situation in your own body that you're
trying to keep ahead of and you've made
the decision to be fed by tube yeah it's
a big change
in your life it was how has that been
and i suppose there must be things
like you miss out on the social side in
some ways of dinner at first or you may
be concerned about that tell me about
that i mean there's a lot of cultural
um norms around sharing food yes you get
invited to dinner you have to work
dinners you have social dinners
food food food
and
suddenly food wasn't going to become an
option for me and i liked food and i
loved going out to dinner and
i loved socializing and you probably
found out i'm a bit of a chatterbox so i
enjoy all that but it wasn't going to do
me any good she thought it was going to
kill me in the end so it was something i
had to get used to
i went to a period of loss of course i
did
but i couldn't tell you what
nine years old
but i don't even think about eating food
well strangely enough i still like
cooking food i like cooking for my
friends
i like going to dinner it's where food
is but um
what i did have to do because
all the invitations
immediately dropped off so suddenly i
thought well this is how it's my social
life to suddenly come to work
and i wasn't gonna have that so
um
some of my friends said oh
um i didn't get invited to dinner
and they said well you know we can't
bear to sit there and eat in front of
you because we feel for you and i go
well
actually i feel worse when you exclude
me so
i'll come to dinner and put a nice glass
of chardonnay on the table and i'll be
fine in fact baking champagne will be
even better so
i said and i'd drink because i can
easily drink like
coffee i've bought myself a good coffee
machine and
enough with coffee and
all kinds of drinks and ice cream i can
studies ice cream and i'll be fine and
again it was i had to reassure them
you said about
if i if somebody asked you if i asked
you about your condition what would it
actually tell you about you
so much of your life you don't wish to
be defined by this and yet
your work has made you extremely well
known in this area
about rights for others equality how do
you marry that up not wanting to be
defined but so much of your work
is around access for those living with
disabilities well i suppose
because
i am not defined
um to be just a disabled person talking
about my own
um i'm interested
in equality for all i
typically i don't just
work on issues to do with
um disability i support my colleagues
who do work around to raise equality and
i do like working with a lot of women's
groups because i actually think that in
sexuality is incredibly important
because i can be a black woman
or i can be a black disabled woman so
you do they're different parts of you
that
basically
um
they speak to different characteristics
so one day i can be sitting around the
board table with some of my colleagues
and they can ignore me
not because i'm a disabled person but
because i'm a woman and i'm sitting with
some very very male
stereotypically male characters and i
have to
really be forceful in order to get my
points across i think i'm fair to say
that i work
in the field of human rights okay
and i just want human rights well i
think that's just everybody i was gonna
say that speaks very closely to one of
the campaigns that you are very well
known for around the world um but if you
look at the uk which is where you have a
role in in the legislation for blocking
assisted dying becoming law
in the uk
others have worked with you of course
but most recently you did this last year
and it does keep coming back
it's not something that goes away for a
while
uh and countries around the world have
moved to legalize it
why are you against it i think if we
lived in a world that treated
people uh sick people
and disabled people like me
equally with respect and not with fear
then i would feel quite comfortable
about having
assisted suicide
legislation
but the truth is that
and we're just knowing this one looking
at our recent pandemic
within the pandemic
disabled people
disproportionately
suffered as a result of what
extraordinary nearly six out of every 10
people who died with covert in england
were disabled or underlying health
conditions were given as the
the pretext for that but but i mean it
was
extraordinary because
i'm very robust
it's because
we didn't have the same access to
exhaustive care
at the internet we couldn't have an
accident even one of my friends was she
was also
a ventilator user was told she could
have filters for her ventilator because
they had to be for
people who were
fit a world and getting governed
and it's true that
when i
went i felt i had
no cancer three years ago
and it was quite serious i didn't know
the operation there and then
my consultants
had to basically
advocate for me
to have that operation because
the view is that actually i'm at end of
life that this is
what i'm defined as because i have a
progressive impairment and that i was
worthless well perhaps you wouldn't want
to be operated on
on her because foreign likely to die on
the table
um why i don't know why
um and also her recovery
you know what would her life be back
like after recovery it's a lot of
clinical assumptions again
like my mother was told
you know your child won't live until
she's too go home and enjoy her well
this vampire celebrate my 63rd birthday
so i know that there are so many
assumptions made so is that your fear
that you know there's a there's a kind
of euthanasia policy there that isn't
being oh i know there is plenty of
examples though
i could tell you all the time
15 years ago when i had pneumonia and i
went i had to go to a hospital that
doesn't know me and they said well we're
not going to resuscitate her because in
her condition
it wouldn't be fair was this said to a
family member it was said to my husband
right and my husband had to go home
and i just received the doctorates and
honorary doctors and some work that i'd
done and he brought the picture back of
me to my graduation card he said this is
my wife she works full-time you do for
her everything that else that you would
do for
anyone else who has that kind of life
you know she's in her 50s
why aren't you giving her antibiotics
why wouldn't you resettata
and it was only at that point they'd be
going to see me in a different backs
and it was all that loaded oh she's got
sma
she's catching on a ventilator she must
be end of life
so
to be clear though
those are incredibly worrying examples
and those are only from your life you
will have heard many many others
but for those who and you will have
spoken to them who are in a situation
where they really do
want to die they are in an enormous
amount of pain
it isn't a life
for them anymore as far as they see it
absolutely and they need assistance
how do you speak to them about your view
and the the role you've played blocking
what they want to become law what i say
is
at the moment there are not the
safeguards
there is not the kinds of attitudes that
we know that would safeguard thousands
of thousands of disabled and older
people in this country who need
palliative care and who need the support
to live
with dignity and not in pain
and until that's there
if we bought in that bit this bill for
these one or two
exceptional cases
we will be putting
hundreds of people in dire risk i mean
you you should say you were a protester
you know long before you were in
and
you may still feel you are but i meant
that was very much what you were doing
for a long time but i was doing women's
rights before i was doing disability
rights well and that's what i did i
didn't just say in this area though you
were a protester that was a lot of what
you were doing what was the naughtiest
thing you got up to as a protester that
you wouldn't be able to do now as a
member of the house of lords
it took 50
wheelchair users
we made sure that we would most of us
were in electric wheelchairs because you
cannot lift them
and we just crossed the switch the
bridge and we stopped
and we stayed there for an hour and a
half and we got little play cards out
saying right it's not charity because we
wanted
civil rights we didn't want to be seen
as charity cases that we had no civil
rights
no right to go in any building
no right
to stay in your own home that could put
you in a residential home at any point
no rights absolutely not not to go on a
bus not to do anything
and so that's when it all began and um
i just thought it was the best day of my
life and what did the police do
they didn't know whether to arrest us or
give us an ice cream and put it on
to be absolutely honest they were
bewildered because here are all these
what they sort of thoughts were poor
pathetic creatures sitting in the middle
of the road going up towards your
officer and they said would you please
know where we were
sorry
that was dead
and we were just winding them up and
they kind of quite liked it
um the second time we did it
they were a bit more prepared so they
walked us down to the police station
but of course it was two steps up to the
door so we couldn't get in
and so they tried to kind to say that
you know
it was difficult
there were some deaf people with us they
divided
them outside language interpreter
someone else wanted something in braille
and then he had
and this was our time
and it was a very liberating moment
um
and that's why
we often talk about the disability
movement and they said what what was it
and i said it was our
liberation struggle
just like
women had
many years ago
and we had to go through that period of
being suffragettes from throwing bricks
or sitting in the road
but then it was time to negotiate and i
think that's when i became
very interested in politics and the
political machine because i knew at the
end of the day we needed legislation i
wanted to ask what what is top of your
list to achieve for those living with
disabilities around the world if you
could
get one thing really in a better place
i want them to feel
personally in control of their lives
i want them to believe
that they
have
life chances but they
can get a job or if they feel they can't
work that they can contribute
in some way whether that's artistically
whether that's socially
i just want disabled people
not to sit at home watching dating
tv
and feeling sorry for themselves it's
because that makes them socially dead
i just want them to feel alive and i
want them to be to enable them in some
way
to feel empowered because once you get
involved and you have a bit of
confidence
you can do anything
honestly you can yeah even block the
road yeah with a group of your friends i
didn't promise that i wouldn't
anymore when i went into the
department
baroness jane campbell thank you so much
for talking to me and to all of us well
thank you very much it's been a real
pleasure thank you and thank you so much
for being with us until we meet again
take care and goodbye
[Music]
you